in a remote corner of the Caribbean
researchers have turned 16 tiny islands
into miniature ecological experiments
what they found could change the way
that we think about invasive species and
it's all because of one little lizard
[Music]
this is a brown anole it spends its time
sat on tree trunks waiting for food to
wander along the ground hunting down
here keeps brown and Knowles
out of the way of the green anoles who
hunt up in the trees but when a new top
predator is introduced into the
ecosystem this all changes this is a
curly tailed lizard curly tails eat
brown and oles as well as competing for
the same food in response the brown
anole spend more of their time up in the
branches away from the curly tails but
now they're competing with the green
anoles for food prevailing ecological
theory suggests that having predators
around should increase the diversity of
an ecosystem by keeping prey populations
in check so do the curly tails benefit
the other island species a team of
ecologists decided to investigate they
introduced curly tailed lizards to
several small islands in the Bahamas
these islands are self-contained
ecosystems with similar habitats by
tracking the lizard populations and
their behavior the researchers were able
to examine exactly what happens when a
new top predator arrives what they found
was that when the brown anoles
took refuge in the canopy they drove the
green anoles to extinction in two out of
the four populations studied in this
case it seems that introducing predators
has actually decreased the diversity of
the ecosystem if this kind of
interaction is calm
it could have important implications for
conservation human activity has
introduced invasive predators into
ecosystems across the world if predators
are damaging diversity in this way
conservationists may need to work even
harder to control their spread back in
the Bahamas the ecosystems on these
islands have been changed for good but
it's allowed this team of researchers to
challenge a core principle of ecology
and it's deepened our understanding of
the role that predators play in
structuring ecosystems
you